it's really shouldn't be a flex to be
able to drink without a chaser but
because I'm around so many dudes it is
the flex it is there is something about
seeing a girl just throw back a shot of
tequila and not even Flinch and like
your nipples get hard I say straight up
like every bartender I go to I'm like
can you make it look I'm a [ __ ] yeah
okay she's like I think we're trying a
little meth before just casually said it
like I tasted meth [ __ ] where I've gone
I've been through some [ __ ] in my life
but I haven't accidentally asked Can I
taste some beer man like accidentally
the people in this room yes and if all
people in this room that you would have
thought to tried meth it wouldn't be the
one with the baby
Mike wants you
Mike Mike
Michael
stop playing
oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi welcome back to another episode of
Big Move hey hey how's it going we
missed you how are you did you wash your
ass today good listen we got a beautiful
intros like I never know what she's
gonna say before she introduces me
oh we have all of that word the voice
that you just heard if you guys are
releasing you're not watching who are
you baby tell them who you are my name
is Nikki blades I'm so happy to be here
with you guys and every time she speaks
a cat meows because she is a the cat
literally went wrong he responded to
your room and we also have we have
Tiffany here this is uh Tiffany Del Rio
yeah that sounded hot oh really yeah I
just wanted to be out of breath
so I decided to just talk
and I'm Gina
what's up come here boy everybody
listening right now I was like what is
happening in my ear getting there all
nice and deep black so
um I don't know when this episode's
gonna come out but last time we played a
card game together and we had so much
fun yeah it's the last episode of the
day and we're like you know what let's
let's play some more card games because
that was just like we had a good time so
that's what we're gonna do now we're
playing a game that you guys have if you
guys have been following for a long long
long long time even before the podcast
it's a game called drunk Stone stupid uh
and they're good friends of ours and
like this is one of my most favorite
games ever basically how it goes is we
pull these cards what it says on there
we determine if that pertains to us or
not it's like a game of like um who does
this card describe okay yeah we can tell
stories from it perf all right yeah so
we have our Stacks here I'm gonna
shuffle them up shuffle them up my OCD
is uh getting the best of me because
right now I'm just making sure that all
the drunk zone stupid logos are facing
the same direction oh gosh all right I'm
gonna pull first then okay okay first
card says sucks at telling stories
so she
yeah I can't tell a story straight
do you know what is it because you can't
remember the story or like what's the
reasoning you know what I feel like it's
it's a similar thing that happens when I
write I hand write things okay my brain
is like too excited with too many things
and like I can't focus on a one-track
way of thinking that can flow very
cohesively and just like with
handwriting like my hand gets stuck
because like I want to write faster than
what I'm capable of doing and so when
I'm actually telling a story I'm having
a I'm having so many thoughts in my
brain that I'm like jumping from this
thought and I didn't get to fully flesh
out the thought so I'm like jumping and
jumping and jumping like when I re-watch
things that I'm in
I get so frustrated with myself when I'm
listening to the stories because I'm
like I know what I was trying to say but
it didn't come out of my mouth and I get
it man I I wholeheartedly will receive
that card
and say I agree you know who I want to
tell my life story
who's that guy that Mexican guy in all
the Marvel movies
oh he's so funny Enrique Pena yes I want
him to be at my funeral yeah it's just I
feel like it'd be so funny and then she
did this and then but then she got
arrested for this and then it just keeps
on going yeah and then everyone would be
too like they'll be laughing too hard to
cry yeah that's how I grew up like all
my friends would speak that way amen I
love it and then I love it
always makes the executive decision
I don't like making decisions I'm
thinking that's you huh yeah yeah you
yep you scared me I know what I want to
do and what I don't want to do if I'm
ever in a position there's certain
friends that I'm like look
I don't want to be in control you
literally have to just do everything I
cannot have a say because the moment I
have a say I'm going home because you're
only going to want to do what I want to
do like either y'all make all the plans
or I have to make all the plans and if I
have to make the plans I'm not happy I'm
one of those people I'm like if I'm
leaving my house we have to have a plan
and when [ __ ] starts going down I am the
first person to be like
this way get out we gotta go no problem
putting the foot down I like it when
it's just like I don't have to plan
anything yes you know what are you what
are we doing tell me what to do I'll go
do it that's fine I don't want to plant
anything you to the tea I love that in a
relationship uh if I can just trust you
to make all the plans because I am known
for making the executive decision I'm
normally the one that's gonna be like
yes or no if I can trust you and you
just make it all happen oh yeah and I
become real spoiled with like the people
that I've been talking to that I've you
know been with now I'm like Oh my
standards are so look if you don't know
how to book a trip have a flight have
all of it situated like don't even
bother me oh I dated someone like that
once oh I had to book
our plane tickets two hours after
getting my wisdom teeth pulled out
because he's like well I'm at work and
I'm busy [ __ ] I'm drugged up no
no yeah major green flag is if you can
book my flight and have everything
figured out
there's a big difference between oh what
do you want to do this weekend and I got
us reservations
oh get dressed let's go
and when they just know when you don't
even have to think about the Uber when
everything is already planned out and
you just let a boss asked me oh please
I'm just looking for a man's that can
make executive decisions yeah yeah
that's hot brain off tell me what to do
I want a little bit of both so I I'm the
one that plans everything executes
everything literally like Casey doesn't
have to ever think and if I ask him to
think for a little bit he's overwhelmed
he's like wait what wait where's the
thing that we're what and I'm like I
just said where it is
I was like work of like trying to not
that he doesn't have race Health it's
like he just doesn't like to to figure
things out yeah so I like it's it's like
a it's a Bittersweet thing because I
like to be in control yeah I'm a very
controlling kind of person like OCD and
[ __ ] like you saw the freaking cards
right now so that's part of my
personality so I'm glad that he's like
that to a certain extent yeah but then
when I ask for like a little bit of help
or like can you just figure this one
thing out and then he can't do it that's
when I get frustrated yeah but not that
he can't just most of the times he
doesn't I've seen so many comments that
talk about like uh
Nikki's so independent that's why she
can't find a man I'd be like you should
be surprised at how I am in a
relationship I am right so not
independent I'm not I'm only independent
out of necessity it's a survival tactic
I only do this because I have bills to
pay and also I don't like being told
what to do by people that don't deserve
to tell me what to do but let me tell
you
I love me a bossy I like somebody that I
will if you can get me to listen to you
one thousand percent I will literally do
whatever you want yeah
same oh love it should I keep that card
should we count how many cards we end up
having oh yeah sure okay so that's yours
so this is mine here you go yeah okay
okay all right is obsessed with how they
look in photos give me this [ __ ] it's
Gina's card this is my career okay I got
paid to do this I always tell them like
before we posted her photos send it to
me first gotta make sure it's okay yeah
and then we like okay okay it's approved
okay go ahead yeah we must have our
photos approved by Gina even like my
social team at G4 they know yeah
I think I've come to terms with certain
things like today is the least amount of
makeup I think I've ever worn you look
amazing on camera I love your freckles
appreciate it I walked in I actually
wish you were wearing less because when
you walked in you had way less yeah I
put a little you look great I put a
little concealer on just because I was
like I feel like I love tired but
everybody was like no you look fine I
was like okay [ __ ] it let's just go for
it but maybe two three years ago no way
but I'm trying to be more comfortable in
my skin but yeah I've started to like
let go of that a bit yeah I literally
never wear makeup anymore these days
except for when I know I have to film
yeah but that's like almost never now
these days because even if I Vlog I
don't put makeup on I think it's a nice
combination of the two I feel like it's
a good balance sometimes not to wear too
much is like I feel good today I feel
comfortable with you guys we're you know
we're solid and also I wasn't feeling
the best so I hate
overthinking my look I'm like you know
what I just want to go I don't want to
worry about it hairs back we're cool
yeah but on any other time I'd be like
Glam let's put the lashes on let's go
hair is out let's make it happen just
depends on the day I have to wear makeup
so much now and I hate it why because
back then even when I was Go-Go dancing
all I did was eyes and lashes and that's
it I never wore Foundation yeah but now
like it started in 2000 I think 17 when
I started streaming not to wear makeup
every day because I'm streaming every
day and then we also have makeup artists
at G4 now oh and that's going to have to
do your own makeup thank God yeah do
they remove it too no because I bring it
home and I use it to stream so I can
it's perfect yeah yeah if I had a makeup
artist I'd do it all the time yeah have
you guys ever had so this is a side
tangent here but I once got a facial and
they were the way that they removed my
mascara was life-changing whoa so this
is in South Korea and I went to the
studio spa oh yeah yes they're like
super high-end
brand I got the most amazing facial
massage in my whole life and the way she
did it was she got two cotton swabs and
with the makeup remover and then she
went like this oh they sandwich it all
yes and I'm like oh my God
how come no one's ever removed my makeup
like this or like my mascara it's always
down yeah like this and I never thought
of like any other way but she oh she
just did this and I'm like that's how
I'm forever gonna remove so gentle
mascara and it was and then I looked in
the mirror because I'm like she must
have forgotten some of it no it was
[ __ ] clean wow yeah that's amazing
learn something new today yes almost
sandwich off my mascara yes yes yes do
that uh doesn't understand the concept
of personal space
foreign
try if this was any other corporate I
like I would have gotten hard oh no for
everything that I do but the threats
that I make yeah what okay here we go
what is it would Trash Talk the Special
Olympics
hahaha
no
no that's her card no that's your card
no I am just put that in your pile and
we'll move on
don't fight it let's move on let's just
move on just
dances on tables I will give it to
blades
this is for you girlfriend I do like to
dance on the tables even though Gina did
it as a profession she did but I don't
know you just you screamed this Aura to
me yeah like you would be so much fun to
party with yeah I had to do it for work
okay you you're gonna be fun to party
with have a good time yeah you are I'm a
good time
uh has never broken the law
I don't think anybody in this room no
yeah that's other pull another car yeah
can't technology no we literally yeah
next okay actually I could probably take
that because I refuse to try to figure
out you have what
a fridge with a coffee machine that you
can tell to make coffee from your
bathtub yeah
she said I know how to wear Tick Tock
but I know how to tell my damn
refrigerator I make my espresso
Cannot Be Tamed
I feel like it's the right person you
want to split that card like we'll just
put that in the middle that's both of us
the right person
you are more attainable than me right
now probably yeah
she wants the card yeah you take it yeah
it takes the right person somebody
contained this wild giraffe yeah I don't
know how you tame a giraffe but let's
try it out you know what I'm saying all
alone turtleneck
[Music]
oh my God can you imagine one day
there's gonna be two big ass people me
and my significant other walking around
all you gonna say like y'all see them
two big ass
she's like there goes Nikki and her
giraffe man not a giraffe I love that
yes absolutely guys shorter than you I
don't know I don't know have you no no
um not seriously I chalk it up too it's
not because they're the problem it's
because me I'm not strong enough to do
that well I just haven't met anybody
interesting enough like their
personalities haven't been that good
I'm stupidly attracted to tall men it is
one of my biggest downfalls it honestly
is a character flaw
if I could change anything about myself
it would be my attraction to tall men
why because most of the
most they've been walking the Earth like
Greek gods their whole lives they need
to be humbled they have always been that
guy no matter what like developing a
personality as a tall guy is not
necessary it's like a girl being
beautiful her whole life not having an
ugly face you know what I mean there's
some girls that you're like oh you've
never had to try huh
you know what I mean like you don't need
to know what two plus two is it's all
right she's like banana you know not at
least you're pretty right like one of
those most tall guys smoke not all but
most of them don't have to try so that
is my biggest character flaw yeah
but I like funny guys oh
embarrassment to me all right okay has a
dark side oh
damn I mean hold on wait your dark side
shows so you're not having that yeah
it's not a surprise but tip has like a
whole other life yeah
yeah
I look at this life and I'm like
oh yeah there was once a time where I
literally got high off air fresheners
every day yeah like yeah like your dark
side is a part of your personality yeah
yours is like it's always a pleasant
surprise we hear story like I've heard
the stories but every time you say it
I'm like
she's so she's like I think we're trying
a little meth before just casually said
it like I tasted meth [ __ ] where I've
gone I've been through some [ __ ] in my
life but I haven't accidentally asked
Can I taste some beer man like
accidentally the people in this room yes
and if all people in this room that you
would have thought to tried meth it
wouldn't be the one with the baby right
you know he's new and she casually said
it yeah how do you think the baby got
here right
right he's like and I'm nothing to you I
just don't exist Does your probiotic
contain clinically studied strains well
rituals symbiotic plus contains two of
the world's most studied strains with
over 350 publications of human clinical
trials before I got to try rituals
symbiotic plus I was taking random
probiotics that I found at the grocery
store no idea if they were good no idea
if they were effective and now I've
actually been really enjoying my gut
health I'm not going to get too detailed
since I started taking ritual let me
tell you what makes ritual so special
they're science-backed and research
stacked especially when stacked up
against the leading direct to Consumer
and top selling probiotics on the market
this is actually more than just a
probiotic with three in one clinically
studied prebiotics probiotics and a
post-biotic to support your balanced gut
microbiome and it's just one daily
capsule for a simple streamlined gut
support the delayed release capsule is
designed to help reach the colon and not
just the stomach which is an ideal place
for probiotics to survive and grow and
there is no Refrigeration needed the
moisture-controlled bottle technology
was designed to protect the probiotic
strains symbiotic plus and ritual are
here to celebrate not hide your insides
there's no more shame in your gut game
that's why ritual is offering our
listeners 10 percent off during your
first three months visit ritual.com big
mood to start ritual or add symbiotic
plus to your subscription today go to
ritual.com big mood going to the mod to
get your ears pierced used to be a rat
of Passage if you look around today it
may seem like a tattoo parlor is your
only option to level up your ear game if
that's not your thing and you want a
grown-up alternative to the traditional
piercing shop then check out studs studs
is reimagining the piercing experience
for each and every ear want to refresh
your look with a new piercing or need
Pro styling advice shop online or stop
into studs in La NYC Austin Nashville
Miami Boston or Seattle with more coming
soon want to get a new or even a first
time piercing but feeling a little
scared fear not studs only pierces with
single-use needles never guns so it's
way safer and better especially for
advanced piercings studs earrings are
made from high quality materials which
won't turn your skin green plus they're
lightweight and durable enough to wear
all the time you can even sleep and work
out in them studs has over 250 styles of
Hoops Huggies studs cuffs and dangles
and they pierce way more than just lobes
so it's easy to create a statement look
or something you keep in every day
starting at just ten dollars per earring
I really love my studs earrings that I
have they sent us over some super cute
like Huggies and I even got one that
dangles with the little stuff are and
also some some just like studs I have
one that's I think it's called a
baguette or something it's really cute
though it's like a little rhinestone I
am really impressed with the durability
of these earrings like seeing them
firsthand like they have a little bit of
weight to them and I can tell like these
are really durable I'm also a really big
fan of the mini chunky Huggy that I have
it's so cute and it just hugs my earlobe
perfectly which is great because I have
a baby who tugs at any jewelry that I
have anything shiny but these Huggies
stay on real good and they're so
comfortable to sleep in like honestly
I'm I'm a really big fan and right now
studs is offering our listeners 20 off
your first purchase when you go to
studs.com big mood that's
studs.com slash big mood for 20 off your
first purchase
studs.com slash big mood okay can only
make plans one day out
that sounds like don't hit me up a month
in advance because I can't stay up
because they can't probably can't plan
stuff Miss Dina over here you know she
literally called me last night at 9pm
she texted me after I texted her I'm
like hey Mama Casey and I will be there
at 9 30 to set up and then Blaze is
gonna be there and then she goes she
starts FaceTiming me oh but I had just
put Luca to sleep so I was I kept
answering it wouldn't work I'm like what
the heck is she accidentally butt
dialing me she facetimes me twice audio
facetimes me and then finally a phone
call goes through she goes we're filming
tomorrow i'm like [ __ ] oh so you forgot
about me
so that's what it is
and the whole family's just here in my
house right now you know what's funny
she brought her whole damn family yeah
literally I can look right here too with
Casey so she goes
okay no that's fine that's fine yeah no
no I'll be there I'm like [ __ ] we're
filming in your house
I'll I'll be in my home yeah I will be
there in my home somehow okay guys Gina
we've had this in the books for like a
month over a month yeah so I have like
next months ready and I also have one
this the end of this month all right
yeah that one yeah yeah I wrote those
down I don't know what happened okay
it's fine we're fine we're fine we're
here I made it we're safe but yeah you
get that cart wait yeah
don't worry I got you
uh we'll eventually burn down house
keep your card yeah didn't you
accidentally something
here lots of this yeah I uh I got a
first aid kit from my stream does anyone
keep me alive I actually set that one on
fire within 30 seconds shout out to
Gina's stream like y'all you guys thank
you with the water and appreciates and a
fire extinguisher you're better you're
better at keeping her alive than we are
her friends I didn't even know that that
was a part of my job description I that
becoming a part of this you know family
I had to worry about keeping you up yes
once you enter a friendship she's our
baby I'm a liability wow normally that's
yeah
I'm not the problem
all right
um peaked in high school oh yeah that's
not any of us no no yeah we'll do we'll
do one more it's a total lightweight
here Tiff yes oh God so one of the first
times hanging out with Tiff
is a lightweight and I've experienced it
firsthand yeah and it doesn't help that
when tip came on the podcast when we
were doing No Chaser in the beginning
like Tim and I used to go hard
real hard sorry Chia
um we used to just get real [ __ ] up
even when you were oh remember our
episode like we remember drinking then
yep we drank oh it was worry we actually
had it was blurry we actually had to dub
over so much of ours because yeah
because we were drinking so much and it
was just so loud it was like the first
year so when Tiff came on
we were Reckless oh yeah it's like The
Reckless night so that was before covet
that's too far it's before Kobe that's
why I didn't drink yet so yeah I get it
now it was before no clue wait you
started drinking during coven because I
never really drank before yeah that's
why I'm like wait you drank no you
didn't no she doesn't drink yeah so that
episode that that was kind of like when
we all had to start sobering up a little
bit oh Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
happened we were games no no chaser was
no chaser for a reason oh yeah Chase
yeah no chase we wasn't Rick just
watching all of them yeah because he
doesn't drink yeah breakfast thoroughly
just enjoying all
right
yeah
right we had fun though I am a good time
she's a good time yes oh yeah I want to
drink with you yeah and I am a very
total lightweight yes you know at one
point when we're having dinner I took
the biggest gulp out of this cup because
I thought it was water it was tequila oh
yeah and at that point I had already had
too much oh way too much you made a
phone call that day and then yeah
and I'm like husband yeah
I'm drunk yeah we'll talk about that off
air off air I'm like I'm just we'll talk
about it later we'll tell you later
I don't think so funny anyways okay wait
my turn can't remember [ __ ]
honestly I this is me too girl yeah yeah
but yeah I just feel like that could
just go in the middle because I can't
remember Shady no I have selective
memory wait I can't I can't remember
where anything is mostly no same and you
know what's terrible is when you're the
only person to blame yeah there when
there's nobody else to blame for you
losing something is the worst yeah okay
you just lost your jacket girl all right
I'll [ __ ] talk about that one sorry
I'm the type of person who like
would need something I'm like oh I don't
have it I gotta go buy it and then I'll
buy it and I'll put it away and I'll
forget that I have it and then again now
like what am I doing with 56 boxes of
Post-it notes yeah you know because I'm
so disorganized and it's just like I
like I have like no object permanence oh
you know and then I find the box full of
Post-its I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm the
type of person that will buy the same
thing from the grocery store even though
I still have it in my refrigerator like
completely forgot or it's just like a
habit yeah no for me I am so forgetful
that I don't trust myself to remember
things so I put things in the calendar
right away or I make notes and I still
forget that I have it have you in my
calendar and in my notes have you ever
hid something yes thinking that you
would know where you put it yes and then
you can't find it oh my God passports
for a long time I hate when I think I'm
smart and imagine yeah from other people
but surprise [ __ ] I'm other people
my crypto cold wallet oh my God oh my
God I was I was losing my [ __ ] and then
I found it at the place where I'm like
apparently passion was like I'm gonna
put it here where it's responsible but
current Gina doesn't trust past Gina for
being responsible why is no [ __ ] way
that I was responsible enough to do this
yeah so weird that's so weird I hate
that about ourselves yeah good uh knows
[ __ ] everything I feel like you know
a lot of things you know a lot you can
guide us through life yeah you know
everything I am [ __ ] everything I
know there's so many times where I have
to be like don't say did you know
random fact I actually I'm not an
actually person did you know I love
random facts one of my favorite accounts
to follow is like Uber Facts I love
random [ __ ] yeah those are fun see
there's a lot of random [ __ ] too I feel
like in our space of entertainment you
kind of got to know a lot about every a
little bit about everything yeah
oh is a good liar who's a good liar I'm
the worst [ __ ] liar I think I'm
really obvious when I'm lying yeah yeah
one time I got called out my my friend
was like Gina I know you're lying I'm
like what what do you mean he goes your
voice gets higher when you lie you dip
[ __ ] I'm like oh no no no no no no yeah
that's so funny not really there's
nothing you can tell when I'm lying yeah
yeah I got so traumatized because I was
a big time liar as a kid I don't know
what happened exactly like I really
can't remember I can't remember uh what
happened but something happened in my
childhood that made me like
super afraid to ever lie and now like I
I really just can't [ __ ] lie not even
to save myself for from like playing
games we played this before yeah you
lost terribly yes I can't lie okay well
that's a good quality to have yeah I
mean I mean look you're wrong you just
I'm never gonna commit crimes with you
that's true yeah but you know no I think
I could
but like to come out and just be like oh
yeah here's a lie yeah I can't no well
oh my my turn yeah we'll just leave that
in then
has old person tendencies
if Nikki limo was here oh yeah Nikki is
ancient also the the nose [ __ ]
everything would be Nikki limo yeah it's
something with the Nikki name yeah yeah
so do you think you have old people
Tendencies I mean from time to time
that's just because of my job honestly
like me having to go to bed at a certain
time and me needing to behave a certain
way is strictly because of my job if I
did not have this job I would be outside
I would be one of those girls on
Instagram on a boat
I'd be on a boat in a bikini you would
see my ass I have it only fans account
let me tell you I would be out the [ __ ]
side out the [ __ ] side not even outside
out the [ __ ] side out the [ __ ] outside
but because I want to have a husband one
day and think that having a stable job
somehow make me a better person I don't
know I guess I adopt old people
Tendencies yeah so this is for you I
guess so I don't even like it
it's a troll
did the Walk of Shame in a Halloween
costume
discard that one yeah yeah
volunteered to ride in trunk of car oh
yeah I think all of them me right here I
literally just destroyed
and yeah that's a not me no wait who
said all of us I'll just give it to you
because you've literally ridden in this
person claustrophobic I'm not writing in
the dream
yeah nice and you know comfy yeah in the
front seat of G-Wagon yeah no so this
was in Austin and Casey's parents have a
G-Wagon and so they drove down from
Dallas to meet us in Austin
and so we were driving to a restaurant
and Gina was with us and we had the baby
so like every G wagons are yeah
comfortable yeah they're not comfortable
and they're really tiny so yeah it's
like parents Casey Luca me Isaac wasn't
there but she's chilling in the back
Gina was in the back it's like drunk but
not like a trunk the way that I'm
thinking I was still riding a [ __ ]
trunk I don't really care like I would
rather save the trip like I don't want
to Uber just shove me in the trunk no I
would literally ask my mom to let me
chill in the trunk just for fun yeah
because I just I really liked Small
Things practice being kidnapped so
you're also like seven feet tall I died
yeah yeah no do not show me anybody no
she's like oh she wanted to ride in the
trunk throw her ass in the bag yeah the
AC right on my face be like tip how you
doing back there and I'm all nice yeah
relax in fetal position my favorite
position
like makes me happy just like freaking
out thinking about it oh well here you
go overreacts to everything wow
laughs
he's a [ __ ] drunk of a car yes that's
a proper situation to react to she's
like I don't overreact everything okay
I'm not like a little baby girl God not
everything [ __ ]
that's a justifiable thing to overreact
to it you want to shove me in the trunk
of a car why I'm asking you why practice
Yeah practice that's why I was told no
one's gonna steal your baby they're
gonna give you right back oh God never
learns oh
in Wyatt though
yeah it's a good
one's what I guess in life I mean I do
and I'll be honest in relationships I
learned the whole way I was gonna say
yeah I was gonna say and put that right
yeah we are dumb [ __ ] yeah stupid
supervisions brag's about not you seeing
a chaser
[Music]
it was death shout out to Chaser gang
shout out no chaser gang tune in every
Wednesday dropping a new episode that's
right I'll need a chaser I'll drink it
straight up I can never never
thinking about alcohol makes me want to
go like this yeah so it's really
shouldn't be a flex to be able to drink
without a chaser but because I'm around
so many dudes it is the flex it is there
is something about seeing a girl just
throw back a shot of tequila and not
even Flinch and like your nipples get
hard I say straight up like every
bartender I go to I'm like can you make
it look I'm a [ __ ] yeah okay
yeah I'm a little [ __ ]
yeah and I'm over here I'm like I need
to taste it if not I'm gonna drink all
of it yeah yeah I showed you
I mean I just like alcohol so she's the
devil oh yeah I can't relate has has
bursts of compulsive cleaning
for me yep yeah yeah that's me well you
know what it's mainly bursts of
compulsive organizing well I feel like
that's the like okay
between side and organizing oh yeah no
there is a difference yeah I hate
cleaning but I love
God I wish I had those skills because I
need to you know my laundry would
appreciate that did you see
I love your room why because I want to
organize it so bad but but you know what
sucks we waited too long because I had a
lot of time when I was pregnant and then
now that Luca's here I really can't
afford the time to come over and help
you organize babies [ __ ] up my life I
know other people having kids you've
known me longer true this thing is new I
know selfish sorry I know right doesn't
it have a dad right
maybe when he's older and he's off of
breast milk I think I'll come back
that's gonna be like I don't know in a
year or something uh maybe an alien Gina
may be an alien yeah find me because
you're just I don't know
I feel like it would be you out of us
out of the three of us you would be the
alien
okay I'll keep that going okay
plays drinking games for Glory not
drinking for Glory not drinking I feel
like you would play them for drinking
yeah because you're really competitive I
am really competitive yeah that's for
you girl it is damn these drinking ones
really just that's all for you wow goes
missing within within 15 minutes of
going out
that just sounds funny to me who goes in
my a I never go MIA I used to put are
you a runner no
my mouth and actually I would vote you
really yeah why because she disappear
yeah you disappear in the times when
we've gotten airbnbs and we try to party
it up between us
and we bring other people hmm you go
away really
oh you know what it's because I was
stressed out and [ __ ] arguing on text
yep so then that's that's you no okay so
one of those times was that and then
another one of those times was the
opposite reason
you were happy
I could already tell you what happened
and I wasn't even there okay I'll just
put two and two together I don't go
missing we all we all all don't hang out
we might all get a little too close
trust me if we're all hanging out you're
not disappearing
[Laughter]
oh he's best friends with Uber driver
you I do I really you do yeah she does
so much fun I love him so much she's
literally actually me too yeah I still
keep in contact with me
I've never done that that's all you
though wait so you're still in contact
with an Uber so [ __ ] dope she was so
fun we had like an hour and a half drive
and she was just telling me about how
like we follow each other on Instagram
and on Twitter and she I think she
actually watches this podcast so shout
outs so she uh was telling me about her
love for Janet Jackson and how she's
gone to every concert and she's like
like every time she goes to the Janet
concert Janet knows her oh like they've
literally been like tight and she was
actually you know it's wild I'm so when
we had this drive she was telling me
that her childhood best friend she was
like do you watch Empire and I'm like no
I don't watch that show like yeah do you
know Jesse's uh yeah and I'm like no I
never heard of him like yeah my boy like
I love him so much best friend all this
stuff and then the whole [ __ ] happened
yeah with the whole Scandal and stuff
and then I'm I'm like girl what happened
and she was like he didn't do it he
didn't do it but then later she was like
oh yeah he did it what do you do I don't
know oh we'll have to catch you up yeah
yeah okay anyway that's your friend
that's that's crazy I've never really
driver no me neither yeah we follow each
other mine are normally 70 and don't
know what Instagram are
[ __ ] old heads always get the old ass
grandpa on the way to the airport when
I'm running late I'm nice but I'm like
pop pop Putt-Putt and I'm saying can we
put oh my God yeah this totally belongs
to me because it was another time oh my
gosh
uh he ended up telling me like he was
super friendly and he was taking me to
the airport and I don't know like he
ended up telling me about how like his
wife and him love to cook food and like
invite a lot of people and
um he's from like the Fiji islands and
I'm like oh I have a friend who's from
the Fiji islands and she says it's
amazing whatever go go to talking and
then next thing you know we exchanged
phone numbers and he's invited me for
dinner I didn't go
but that's why we said that she would be
the first one yeah to be sacrificed
we like I was actually kind of nervous
because I'm like oh [ __ ] maybe I should
have given him like a wrong number or
something I don't know he could be
creepy who knows you don't know these
things I have a little bit of Street
Smart just a little bit is this why you
practice being in the trunk of the car
yeah
right
hey
get into the truck
just every trunk to know where the
switch is to get out yeah no you kick
the light out got it see I know but yeah
so I was nervous and I told Casey I'm
like oh [ __ ] like does Uber driver who's
really nice and you know me I can't say
no I'm In Too Deep all the time until I
ended up I ended up giving him my phone
number and he like texted me just to
make sure it really was my number and
then so I'm like so I don't know he's
inviting us to dinner so I don't know
like we'll see when I get back and then
I'm like [ __ ] I really hope he doesn't
text me now because now I'm kind of
nervous that maybe he's like not that
friendly and then Casey was like we'll
see what happens
oh wow he's probably like this girl's
[ __ ] weird
like give me her number she's like
texting his wife babe you would never
guess what just happened to me in the
car guys
and then another Uber driver oh my God
who's trying to say no no somebody pull
a card and I'm kidding oh my God I'll go
always has their hand in their pants
no no discard
[Music]
interprets everything as flirting
interprets I'm the opposite of that
do you feel like you interpret
everything as flirting everyone's always
flirting yeah there you go but I'm also
flirting with everyone I know you
definitely flirt a lot I flirt a lot so
I don't know if you receive it as flirty
no I feel like I know how to make people
uncomfortable
um yeah I don't know I don't think
everybody's always flirting with me I
know that for a fact like I I can tell
when somebody's flirting but I one
thousand percent am the person flirting
all the time it's just fun
can't drive for [ __ ] I'm a great driver
I am too
I I feel like my exes would say
otherwise but I could [ __ ] drive
I say the same thing about myself hey
throw that in the middle yeah but shout
out to all of our exes who have uh
opposite opinions yeah or my mom or my
husband yeah
I could drive damn it yeah it's your
turn oh
uh responds to everything with me no I
think we are very enthusiastic people is
scared of old people no no that's weird
yeah that's a strange fear it would make
a horrible doctor all of us I would not
trust any one of us as a doctor I would
have no bedside manners just walking
through the room you're dead as [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm sorry oh my God you would be
mean I'm flirting with everybody yeah
what am I what would you like yeah no no
no you would cry the whole time yeah no
but I'd be like [ __ ] how many milligrams
yeah you would actually you would
accidentally kill somebody you'd
accidentally kill somebody I would think
I'm in a porno every day and Gina would
just be brutally honest and way too mean
yeah I remember my mom when I was little
I told my mom I was like I want to be a
pharmacist she goes you're gonna kill
people oh my God because you're gonna
forget like yeah measurements and stuff
I was like oh my God you're right that's
that dream immediately yeah you are so
right so funny I think that it would be
pretty exciting to walk into an office
and see one of us in there like how
exciting would that be yeah
this is my doctor yeah
when did you get your degree
sorry you don't got to pull your pants
down your throat hurt my throat does
hurt [ __ ]
I have assisted in a surgery what why
okay oh yeah I used to work in a
hospital I assisted in a finger surgery
once I scrubbed in and everything and I
was helping the doctor pull the
retractor and everything yeah yeah it
was so cool I've also sat in
and witnessed and open that was my first
surgery I ever witnessed an open heart
surgery wow and they kept telling me if
you're gonna faint faint backwards oh
okay like literally his whole chest was
like white so his head was like in front
of me and then his whole chest was right
like wide open in front of me and this
was when they already did the bypass
which means his heart had stopped
so I literally looked in the chest of a
cavity of a man whose heart had stock
yeah if I was to walk into the office
and see you as my nurse I wouldn't freak
out I'd be okay if I saw you then I
would also tell you like can you please
double check the measurements I feel
like I would trust you though I was a
phlebotomist too by the way I would
trust you yeah I drew Casey's blood when
we first started dating he was scared
[ __ ]
I can see you like yeah yeah you I
wouldn't trust no [ __ ] at all you
know the reason why I can't become a
doctor it's because okay like I said
bedside manners if someone came in and
said oh no you know what I'm going to
heal my yeast infection with crystals
listen here you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay those crystals are not gonna do
[ __ ] for you all right so I can't I
would get I would get the worst ratings
on you we all get it I guess yeah yeah
oh
my God I'm flirting with you Mike wants
you
Mike Mike Mike
Michael
stop playing everybody's watching oh my
God
it's not okay let's get it
oh stop guys you're making me blush the
best time to prepare for growth is
before the opportunity arrives
especially for online businesses if you
have an online business then ship
station might be something that you want
to check out I think it definitely is
something you want to check out because
ship station sets you up for growth by
directly integrating with every shopping
cart and storefront so your products are
easier to find they're easier to manage
and they're easier to get in the hands
of happy customers don't wait until
you're drowning in orders to find the
right shipping solution get dumb dumb
upgrade to ship station today the
holidays are coming up that means it's
about to be a very busy shipping season
I know because I have a jewelry brand
called kittens and coffee that we send
out I mean we do campaigns and usually
we do them around the holidays and uh we
have to send out a lot of things all at
once like it's just it's not just a
sporadic it's all at once and so
preparing for shipping out a bunch of
stuff is definitely necessary whether
you're starting small or scaling up
shipstation makes ship happen there's no
more limiting your business to one store
shipstation integrates with every
platform including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify it makes it really easy to
manage all your shipping from one simple
dashboard so you can maximize your sales
with minimal effort there's so many
companies that already use shipstation
130
000 plus companies actually and ninety
percent of the companies that use
shipstation for one year become
customers for life including companies
that you probably know like chubby
shorts sock Club daily look I use daily
look all the time they're saving so much
money with shipstation so ship more and
grow more with ship station go to
shipstation.com and sign up with promo
code big mood for a free 60-day trial
start today and get set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
that's two free months visit
shiftstation.com Click the microphone at
the top and type in the code big mood
b-i-g-m-o-o-d okay it discovers the
meaning of life on a daily basis
discovers a meaning oh my God if you
ever read my tweets that would be me
yeah unfortunately like what does that
mean I mean I I'm enlightened every
other day give me a tweet of yours what
did you tweak recently I started golfing
and I think I've found my purpose she
finds a purpose every week you know what
I mean like every year I've discovered
something new and I'm like keep it acai
bowl last week and changed her life
because I decided to become healthier do
you know what I'm saying like every time
I take my vitamins I'm just so proud of
me yeah I get that absolutely do a [ __ ]
ton of yoga
I'll tell you that it's a cult
argues over beer pong rules
I think closest would be you yeah [ __ ]
yeah yeah I've only played two games in
my life oh really I've had full-blown
arguments over house rules you have to
just you have to have house rules if you
don't then it leaves it up for
interpretation when it comes down like
this because I am the [ __ ] stickler
for [ __ ] like in our household owner
whenever we play like family games I'm
the fun Ruiner oh no because I'm just so
like wait no but like you didn't do it
it's your turn don't forget like no no
now we're going the other way if we're
playing Uno yeah I'm like the [ __ ]
stickler and I hear myself
and I'm like stop just have fun you
can't [ __ ] help maybe I have a glass
of wine before you play mm-hmm see like
I'm not too concerned about that but I
am like the one that wants to win and
this happens because my sister is more
like that and we are so competitive if
we're on the same team we think exactly
the same you never want to go against me
and my sister I'm really competitive oh
we can finish each other's sentences
it's ridiculous like we're right there
but the moment you put us on the
opposite the younger one yeah yeah the
younger one oh the moment she is on the
other side because we can finish each
other's sentences we are going all out
like it is personal it's [ __ ] not fun
so it's kind of like competing against
yourself yes you're like I need to be
better than but she's meaner than me my
sister is way meaner than I am she's the
one that goes oh great but when we play
together oh we can play games together
all day so much fun yeah that's awesome
things are in The Matrix
me yeah
I'm like we're totally yeah
especially after taking germs and seeing
the sky with a horizontal not horizontal
what is it vertical hexagon hexagon
Skies yeah I was like I could see them
for a moment
hey all right I'm kidding no no she's
like so serious not really yeah wake up
Tiffany wake up she's like I don't want
to not yet the episode's not over yeah I
don't know I'm just waiting for the
curtain call I don't know and we'll see
what happens I feel it
gets popcorn buckets from the trash for
free refills oh gross oh God no no I
think that's anyone um
[Music]
we live at home if they could
you yeah you never leave no everything's
super at home there's food
outside I hated my first home my second
one was pretty chill
yeah
that's what that means right like going
back to your childhood home yeah or just
in the house
because I currently live in my home what
do you mean I'm confused wait what does
it say would live at home if they could
I think like we're your parents and
everything like yeah yeah okay that's a
hard pass for me I literally left when I
was 17 because I'm like I don't want to
be here I'm not going back so that's a
no and then I moved out okay goes to
foreign country to find themselves
don't look at me it's between you and me
yeah no I mean you're gonna hurt you
girl you think so yes I did find my home
yes you were living living in Japan for
like months yeah that's true yeah okay
so what happened
um back then when I had like when I
first started making money and I was
just like streaming I didn't have like a
9-5 whatever I was like no I'm just
gonna buy a one-way ticket to Japan see
what happens to stay out there for like
five months or so and yeah my life and I
used to go like two or three times a
year and then come back yeah and now I
have a day job yeah oh I think it was
the best I loved it so much yeah uh is
secretly in love with a friend
um
no
might have killed somebody no no what
you mean but you better hold that card
she hesitated
you hesitate that's yours you killed
allegedly your ego there you go
yo play
yo play we'll make a great cougar
you mean for sure I mean what what yeah
yeah hello yeah oh my God oh my God yeah
that's your car absolutely I would clean
your pool oh my God yes gotta be legal
though yeah gotta be legal hell yeah oh
I can't wait that's why I knew my first
husband gonna die anyways who's telling
you I'm gonna inherit everything I'm
gonna have me a pool bar and Gina's
gonna be there yeah I know of course she
knows okay I do you don't got somehow
split that card because you've literally
done a series
living together it's my first husband
yeah we're gonna be living together and
having like the gardener the pool boy
taking turns yeah the driver right the
security guard sure the cook the chef
yeah oh the chefs
oh the chefs
oh yeah yeah I haven't even played out
that fantasy yet oh my God I would love
to date a chef I wonder what that would
be like yeah if a man cooks for me I'm
married you had an opportunity girl
I mean
oh oh oh oh oh oh not really not really
it's just fun yeah it was just funny I
think okay I'm gonna throw this into the
Universe I want to um a chef that like
owns multiple restaurants you know what
I mean so he has business savvy but
likes to cook maybe a little mean but
it's like soft for me yeah I like those
when they're mean to other people yeah
oh I love a good [ __ ] to everyone
else except except me I kind of have
that at home oh she's that awesome you
know I do not the [ __ ] part oh the
chef yeah
he's extremely nice yeah he's not an
[ __ ] at all he's like really really
nice yeah he's awesome yeah I have my
chef at home runs shirtless to show off
body
for you girlfriend
for you it's right here in your pile
it's already you're giving it to you
that's all you just follow me on
Instagram
somebody told me once did you not go to
the gym today it's like what why because
you didn't post this picture
I did not
but I'm glad that you pay attention
that's funny
yeah um damn I'm really naked like
it's just a little puppy how cute I feel
like for the right person I'm just a
little
puppy
you baby
I am a YouTube baby always wants a light
[ __ ] on fire always wants to light [ __ ]
on fire you're a pyro yeah me too
actually I had a phase when I was a
child but no she could have it I
literally eat fire she does that's true
yeah she taught me how to eat food wow
yeah what else to teach you how to eat
oh
also I don't drink enough water I don't
want nothing to do with that next
[Laughter]
[Music]
this [ __ ] is always on antibiotics
I'm under the medicine cabinet and
that's why she strictly she said I'm
strictly dickly [ __ ] you understand
what all that is she said I can't even
lie to you right now I said here's your
water and your pills see me in two to
three weeks don't come don't come
knocking him let's go here we go good
job all right uh things but shouldn't oh
I've never heard you guys sing I don't
really sing
I like singing
but I hear you singing you do yeah
sometimes I hear you sing wait what I
sing like like that like just around in
Spanish I do I mean but is it does it
hurt your ears oh okay so then that's
how that card goes around here yeah
discard that one yeah can you sing I
like to sing yeah every once in a while
I haven't been told not to sing yeah me
neither Casey says I sound like a Disney
princess but I'm like you just say that
because you love me no I can see that
though yeah okay
is a little [ __ ]
I don't like the taste of alcohol okay
make it sugary probably like strawberry
flavored something strawberry cucumber
it makes me very happy oh my God
thank you people drink this oh my God
you know what this is the last card just
wants to talk about ass and titties
we're gonna put that right here in the
middle oh no no this one's perfect
because I think it's me would have sex
with themselves that they could oh yeah
yeah I would yeah yeah that's a good one
to end it on literally self-love yeah
someone texted me yesterday saying if
you found out or that you can clone
yourself what would be the first thing
you do and I said I will try to have sex
with myself I swear to God I have it on
my phone right now oh there you go yeah
um
who has the biggest pile this is my pile
I have a tiny one oh [ __ ] oh let's see
blades win I didn't want to win wait
actually no oh yours is bigger
I'm the best person here and of course I
won what do you mean you're the best
because you have you're a good person
well then I'm the best shittiest person
there you go it's gonna be something be
number one at it damn right I
am playing with us we love you the game
is called drunk Stone stupid it's one of
my most favorite games in the whole
entire world make sure you check out Ms
blades here yes in the description box
everything at Nikki blades and also
check out our sponsors all in the
description box also buy something you
[ __ ] coward okay I love you bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]